je n'aurais jamais dû accepter ce paquet
je suis par dealer je te jure pas qu'il
faut que tu me crois bien sûr que je te
crois c'est une affaire fédéral le droit
pénal est très précis à ce sujet jason
risque 10 ans de prison
dix ans at-elle face à sale les états
unis contre jason collins
je respecte la loi sur les peines
planchers je vous en prie je veux juste
de mon fils si votre fils nous aide à
arrêter des dealers nous pouvons obtenir
une réduction de peine
quoi juste viennent une balance jamais
et si moi je le faisais si moi je vous
aider à les arrêter sur nos chantiers
travail plusieurs ex taulard et on a
peut-être un qui a gardé des contacts
j'essaie de reconstruire ma vie ok je le
fais pour ma femme et j'ai juste besoin
qu'on me fasse entrer dans ce milieu je
m'arrête tu m'expliquer ce que tu fais
ici je travaille dans le bâtiment
j'ai pas de marchandise ni de réseau
mais pour tout ce qui concerne le
transport la geste qu'il faut il a l'air
prêt à rentrer dans la partie
ton chauffeur a parfaitement géré la
situation ça pourra nous servir
tu sais vraiment pour quitter maurice
minc est un ex paramilitaire mexicain
région pour le cartel du nuevo leon
travailler pour nous veut dire faire
partie de notre famille c'est également
valable pour ta femme et ton enfance
heures c'est la dernière étape
vous arrivez à la franchir et le juge
libérera votre fiston le chemin du sault
peine tu es jeune tu fais le malin avec
les fédéraux mais qu'est ce qui va se
passer quand ils apprendront aussi
infiltrés ils vont s'en prendre à deux
familles
les hors de question que je laisse l'un
des deux camps nous dicter notre destin
hors de question
quoi que je fasse que je me fasse pas
jason va le payer les 10 prochaines avec
ça et si jamais tu vois tu meurs
si vous suivez la drogue les pions tombe
si vous suivez l'argent c'est le roi oui
mais vous savez qu'il ne s'en sortira
pas
quand tu es sûr que tu vas y arriver
fais moi confiance